what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you got three months without making a
video on how to kill superheroes and
suddenly everybody decides they want to
steal the idea for my video my video
series Oh comics explain is often
imitated never duplicated what's going
on guys this is Rob and with Avengers
infinity war hitting theaters soon I
figured a lot of you guys will be
looking for Thanos related content
because who wouldn't and since he's
probably well I wouldn't say probably
since he is like one of the most
powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe I thought now would be a great
time to figure out how we can kill him
plus people have been asking me in the
comment section to make a video about
this so I'm sure we're gonna see Thanos
die in like in the movies
it won't be in an infinity war that
means that'd be the most anti climactic
thing ever it'll likely happen in
Avengers 4 but today we're gonna cover
that O's as he exists in the actual
comics of Marvel's so those of you guys
who are not familiar with Thanos or
perhaps you just looking about stuff for
infinity war and you stumble across this
channel for the first time Danis was
created in 1973 by jim Starlin and
originally appeared in Iron Man number
55 now later on it was revealed that his
origin was on the moon Titan which
orbits Saturn and his parents belong to
a race called the Eternals a race of
aliens that have a variety of
superpowers like superhuman strength and
telepathy and flight and energy blasts
and immunity to disease and poison and
so on and so forth they can't get tired
basically they're humans that you know
Heather jeans meddled with by the
Celestials but they're basically really
really powerful the other thing is
they're almost nearly intolerable and
can regenerate damage to their bodies
and all this is due to the fact that
they were able to exert mental control
over themselves so while the hold is
strong it basically can be broken
however when Thanos was born it was
discovered that he was actually a hybrid
of an eternal and their cousin race the
deviance now like the Eternals the
deviants were created by the Celestials
but unlike the Eternals they have a
hideous appearance furthermore the
deviance and e-journals are more often
than not at war with one another almost
all the time so they're basically like
people who like the Jedi or the Sith
nobody ever likes both now because of
his deviant appearance Thanos his mother
attempted to kill him shortly after his
birth but was unsuccessful now initially
being a peace-loving child Thanos
eventually became infatuated with and
even began to worship mistress death
who's literally the embodiment of death
in the comics the problem here is that
Thanos was friends own but the whole
idea was that he he basically sought to
cause as much death as he possibly could
and to that end
uses vast scientific knowledge to
bolster his powers and sought out some
of the most powerful artifacts in the
Marvel Universe mainly the Cosmic Cube
and the infinity gems now the question
we have to ask here is how powerful is
Santos well in terms of strength he has
proven strong enough to punch the Hulk
hard enough to send him flying through a
village he's knocked Ron in the accuser
out with two punches and the super
scroll with one because super scroll
sucks and he was able to break out of an
energy conscious to occur aided by
nebula wielding the Infinity Gauntlet I
Thanos is also extremely durable and he
survived energy blasts from the Silver
Surfer with no ill effects is unharmed
by Ronon the accusers Universal weapon
has withstood multiple blows from Thor's
hammer Mjolnir and energy blasts from
Odin and three of Black Bolt screams
which usually destroy anyone who hears
them now in addition to his strength and
durability Thanos is extremely
intelligent he can generate a force
field durable enough to protect him from
the Silver Surfer wielding the power
cosmic and emit energy beams from his
eyes powerful enough to not Galactus off
his feet so with all that in mind it's
not hard to see why killing Thanos is
such a formidable task since he has
survived battles with some of the most
powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe but that leads us to the
question of can he be killed well
fortunately for us the answer to that
question is a resounding yes in fact
there are multiple instances where
Thanos is either died or come incredibly
close to dying during the Brian Michael
Bendis era of guardians of the galaxy
the book flashes back to the events of
the Thanos imperative when Thanos was
trapped in the cancerverse
which is an alternate universe where
death has no effect because she was dead
and where every living thing has
basically been corrupted by a race known
as the many angled ones that's what she
McGrath is if you don't know who he is
don't worry about it if you do yes now
what we end up finding out is it's
star-lord who along with Richard Ryder
has also been trapped in the cancerverse
basically wields a cosmic cube against
Thanos who yells that if startled or
continues to wield a weapon that is
powerful beyond his control
that they will all basically die now
obviously Thanos doesn't die since no
one can die in the can't reverse but the
fact that he believed he would die lets
us know that the Cosmic Cube is capable
of killing Thanos under normal
circumstances or at the very least
Thanos thinks it is the only other
option of this is that Thanos believed
the cosmic key would just wipe them from
existence which is probably the most
likely scenario but another instance
where we see fan o's almost die occurred
recently during Jeff lemierre's run on
the Thanos solo title where he was
infected by the god cancer which is
essentially a terminal illness that was
causing Thanos his body to consume
itself by the very woman that he
worshiped who of course was mistress
death now eventually Thanos was able to
rid himself of the disease by completing
the trial of the god Court which was a
realm that houses the souls of dead gods
which granted him enough power to battle
his son fame who was in possession of
the Phoenix force but there had been
times that Thanos has actually died
during 2015 Secret Wars by Jonathan
Hickman Thanos was killed when Doctor
Doom simply recent sighed his chest and
pulled out a skeleton without any
difficulty now it's important to note
that at this point doom was in
possession of the power of the beyonders
which are basically this omnipotent
ridiculously opie race of beings from
the beyond verse they were powerful
enough to wipe out all the cosmic
entities including the Living Tribunal
so like they were pretty powerful like
they were really strong but the comics
even demonstrate that you don't have to
have one of the most powerful artifacts
in the universe or the power of a God to
kill thanos as in the 2006 annihilation
event we actually see that hoes die at
the hands of Drax a destroyer
after Drax literally rips Thanos heart
out of his chest now it seems like that
shouldn't have worked but you have to
remember that in the comics Drax was
formerly a normal human named Arthur
Douglas who soul was placed in a
superhuman body designed specifically
for killing Thanos that's literally the
reason Drax exists so I don't know if
there's something about Drax
they just allows him to be able to rip
out a nurse's heart but like it did
happen now I would argue because Drax
was designed for the purpose of killing
Thanos he's got superhuman strength and
speed and so on and so forth I mean it'd
be kind of useless to make a character
who was designed to you know designed to
kill another character if they couldn't
actually kill him so like that makes
sense to me it's reasonable to eat but
of course Thanos did not stay dead in
that story as he was placed in a cocoon
by Adam warlock and eventually
resurrected by the universal Church of
Truth who believed the cocoon contained
the Savior Adam warlock and open the
cocoon to release Thanos basically that
happened and then they were just like oh
yeah so like we done goofed so yeah like
like Thanos can be killed now it could
have happened several times throughout
his history but something is always
there to either keep him from dying or
to resurrect him if the Cosmic Cube had
been used against him in the main Marvel
Universe instead of the cancerverse then
he probably would have not if he hadn't
made it to the god quarry the god cancer
my mistress death probably would have
killed him if he hadn't been placed in a
restorative cocoon and resurrected he
probably would have remained dead after
dying at the hands of Drax
now if Marvel hadn't restored the
universe to its previous form after
Secret Wars he'd still be dead after he
was killed by Doctor Doom at least until
Marvel found another way to bring him
back but there are a couple caveats to
this something to bear in mind is that
Thanos if I remember correctly was
banished from the realm of mistress
death and there is also the idea that
because of the fact he was banished from
mistress death when he died
quote-unquote at the hands of Doctor
Doom he just ended up in a realm of
nothingness there was absolutely nothing
there how that realm exists we don't
know because Marvel never bothers to
explain because Brian Michael Bendis
used it as an excuse to bring him back
during Civil War to business is a great
writer but sometimes he is lazy but the
question we have to ask is is there an
in storyline way that we can think to
basically keep Thanos dead if we take
our pick of ways to kill him that's not
really the challenge I mean how can we
keep him dead like that's the real big
answer here and I think the answer lies
with Thanos his greatest desire mistress
death Thanos entire quest for the Cosmic
Cube and the infinity gems his desire to
kill as many people as possible and to
acquire as much power as possible has
all been motivated by his desire for the
approval of mistress death it has always
eluded him so he continues to press on
leaving more and more destruction in his
wake but what if he was able to gain her
approval will you'd have no reason to
continue on he would probably have no
reason to come back to life if he can be
convinced but the only way to gain
death's approval is to not give her the
souls of millions or even billions but
to make the ultimate sacrifice which is
his own life then I think we solved the
problem of keeping him dead I mean in
order to kill thanos permanently I think
we not only have to convince him that
his death is the only thing that will
satisfy mistress death but I think it
would be possible to do that because
even though Thanos is highly intelligent
his intellect is far surpassed by his
ego so I can only really see him buying
into the idea that his soul is so
special so far superior to all others
that it would be the only offering that
would satisfy mr. stack having said that
what people really want to know is how
could we just beat him to death like is
it possible to like beat Thanos to death
really probably not like I would say
probably not I mean here's here's the
thing you gotta keep mine Thanos has
basically gone toe-to-toe against like
earth's most powerful characters the
only individuals out there who could
probably kill Thanos who are earth based
I guess also Douglas if you consider him
because you know he was born on earth
resurrection distracts a destroyer but I
would say like like a reality war / most
likely would be the only person to do it
the Incredible Hulk
wouldn't be able to do it but it's kind
of interesting there because in the
story Santos versus the Hulk you ended
up having a scenario where jim Starlin
wrote a line where if that was basically
said that like he's routinely avoided
fighting The Incredible Hulk
because of the power the Incredible Hulk
has now people will like infer that to
mean that like well The Incredible Hulk
can beat him the good of all can't beat
him because we've never seen it happen
so you know I don't know if that would
actually take the bike take place or not
I mean they fought it like the mindscape
it was it was like the most clickbait
story ever and people were upset about
it the fact that it was so clickbait but
like it would take an exceedingly
powerful character on earth probably a
reality war / or like one of the most
powerful of the fighters like the void
could probably do it blue Marvel maybe
but I don't think he could because he
was one of the many people who fought
against Thanos in the events leading up
to civil war - and he couldn't defeat
Thanos on his own Carol Danvers
definitely can't do it but he's just
that powerful like I mean it would take
a universe level threat to be able to
like fight Thanos to a standstill and
successfully defeat him like it would be
pretty difficult to do but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here -
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]